ever bumped into a glass door it seems
like bats do it pretty often and not
because they're texting a new study
shows that bats failed to recognize
human-made vertical smooth surfaces like
glass windows as obstacles the
researchers placed a vertical metal
plate in the corner of a flight tunnel
then they monitored bats as they flew
through it of 21 bats 19 crashed at
least once into the plate but never into
walls or other objects collisions also
occurred when the researchers placed the
metal plates outside of caves of three
different bat species this is because
smooth surfaces limit bats ability to
navigate through the dark using their
echolocation system bats emit
high-frequency sounds and uses returning
echoes to spot obstacles in their
surroundings but a sleek vertical
surface approached at an angle reflects
away the echoes pooling bats into
recognizing them as open fly ways the
scientists now hope to determine if
windows or glass buildings pose an
ecological threat to bats and how these
animals can learn to deal with them
[Music]